oh
[Applause]
thank you
thank you everyone
I want to thank all of our speakers for
being a part of this event
we're going to hear from a wide range of
voices today
so activists academics politicians
de-transitioners and I'm very grateful
for all of them
I want to thank especially
all of you for coming out here today
to show your support for this cause
now these people here they don't want
you to hear what we have to say because
they're cowards they can't engage in the
argument
all they could try to do is shut us down
and silence us but it's not going to
work we're still here
we're not going anywhere
we're still here
so what is the cause that we are here
for it's very simple we are here to
fulfill one of our most fundamental
obligations As Americans as adults as
human beings and that is to protect our
children
that is why we're here
if we if we will not stand up for them
then who will if it's not us then who
stands for them the people out there
shouting they're not going to stand for
the kids
they stand for victimizing and preying
upon kids so it falls to us
now here's the fact of the matter there
is in this state and all across the
country a conspiracy to Target and
indoctrinate our children into the cult
of gender ideology
a cult which Fosters delusion
intentionally creates an identity crisis
and young impressionable kids
it's a cult which convinces them that
gender doesn't exist that they have no
identity it's a path to confusion and
despair
now for years this has been happening
right here in the state of Tennessee not
far from where we currently stand
as my team and I uncovered Vanderbilt
Hospital got into the gender transition
game because it's quote a big money
maker those are their own words
and soon they were drugging and
mutilating adults as well as children
now
let me ask you let me ask you guys this
as tennesseans
do we believe in castrating children do
we believe in that
no
do we believe in drugging and mutilating
kids
[Music]
you believe in it we don't
are we going to allow this in our state
[Applause]
are we going to do what they want us to
do which is sit back in silence and
allow our kids to be victimized are we
now I have four kids and I have two more
on the way and like so many of you I
live every day constantly aware of the
world that's out there of these people
who want to Prey Upon my kids
my kids have no idea you know what these
people will try to do to them it's not
fair it's not it's not right that our
kids live in a culture in a country like
that
but here's the thing I'm not going to
leave it
to my kids to fight this fight we don't
leave it to our kids we stand up and we
fight
okay it isn't
it
is in our kids battle it's ours
and we're not just fighting to protect
our kids from mutilation in the name of
gender transition we're fighting that
but an even deeper level we are fighting
for truth
that's what we stand for we stand for
absolute truth
that's what we stand for right there
and that brings me
to one final point that I need to make
the other side the side that supports
mutilating and drugging kids
they know they have no argument
they have nothing they can say so they
lie
and one of the most ridiculous lies that
they tell
is that they want to affirm kids
they're not affirming the child they're
affirming confusion they're affirming
despair
that's what they're affirming
[Applause]
[Music]
now we do not affirm confusion we affirm
the child
when a child is confused we affirm him
we give him the sort of affirmation that
he desperately Longs for and needs and
deserves
that's what we do
now
that's our message
and it's a message that we hope
resonates not just across the city or
this state but all across the country
because we're building a movement
and we're not going anywhere
we're not going to rest
we're not going to rest
until every child is protected from this
madness
so the other side they can shout and
they can scream and they could call us
whatever names they want none of that
will dissuade us because this is a
battle of good versus evil
and we are fighting for good
we're fighting for what is true
we're fighting for people who cannot
fight for themselves and shouldn't have
to that's what we're fighting for
we're in this for the Long Haul for as
long as it takes right this is only the
beginning I promise you that
thank you all God bless thank you